capitalism is in this almost encrypted
to says what is great about it also and
very critical of it
capitalism is more an ethical religious
category for me it's not true when
people attack capitalists as a Gotti's
they don't care for no and ideal
capitalist is someone who is ready again
to stake his life to risk everything
bless so that production gross profit
gross capital circulates his personal or
her happiness is totally subordinated to
this this is what I think Walter
Benjamin the great Frankfurt School
Companion thinker had in mind when he
says said capitalism is a form of
religion you cannot explain account for
a figure of a passionate capitalist
obsessed with expanded circulation with
the rise of his company in terms of
personal happiness I am of course
fundamentally anti-capitalist but let's
not have any illusions here you know
what shocks me is that most of the
critics of today cut today's capitalism
feel even embarrassed that's my
experience when you confront them with
the simple question ok we heard your
story protests horrible big banks
depriving us of billions hundreds
thousands of billions of common people's
money
ok but what do you really want what
should replace the system and then you
get one big confusion you get either
general moralistic answers like you know
people shouldn't serve money money
should serve people well frankly Hitler
would have agreed with it especially
because he would say when people serve
money money is controlled by loose and
so on so either this or some kind of a
vague Keynesian social democracy or a
simple moralistic critic and so on and
so on so you know it's easy to be just
formally anti-capitalist but what does
it really mean it's totally open this is
why as I always repeat with all my
sympathy for Occupy Wall Street movement
its result was I call it a Bartleby
lesson bar
of course Herman Melville's Bartleby
you-know-who always answered his favor I
would prefer not to the message of
Occupy Wall Street is I would prefer not
to play the existing game there is
something fundamentally wrong with the
system and the existing forms of
institutionalized democracy are not
strong enough to deal with problems
beyond this they don't have an answer
and neither do I for me Occupy Wall
Street is just a signal it's like
clearing the table time to start
thinking the other thing you know it's a
little bit boring to listen to this
mantra of capitalism is in it last stage
when this mantra started if you read
early critics of capitalism I'm not
kidding someday a couple of decades
before French Revolution in late 18th
century not the miracle of capitalism
that it's rotting in decay but the more
it's rotting the more it drives you know
so let's confront the serious problem
here also let's not remember and I'm
saying this as some kind of a communist
that the 20th century alternatives to
capitalism and market miserably failed
like ok in Soviet Union they did try to
get rid of the predominance of money
market economy the price they paid was
return to violent direct master and
servant direct domination like you know
you no longer were even formally free
you had to obey orders a new
authoritarian society and this is a
serious problem how to abolish market
without regressing into again into
relations of servitude and domination my
advice would be because I don't have
simple answers to things age precisely
to start thinking don't get caught into
this zeldo activists pressure do
something let's do it and so on some no
the time is to think I didn't provoked
some of the leftist friends when I told
them that if the the famous Marxist
formula was philosophers have only
interpreted the world
the time is to change it this is 11 on
fire but that maybe today we should say
in the 20th century we maybe tried to
change the world too quickly the time is
to interpret it again to start thinking
second thing I'm not saying people are
suffering enduring horrible things that
we should just sit and think but we
should be very careful what we do here
let me give you a surprising example I
think that ok it's so fashionable today
to be disappointed that President Obama
of course but sometimes I'm a little bit
shocked by this disappoint because what
did the people expect that he will
introduce that he will introduce
socialism in United States a lot but for
example the ongoing universal health
care debate is an important one this is
a great thing
why because on the one hand it is a
debate which touches the very roots of
ordinary American ideology you know
freedom of choice States wants to take
freedom from us and so on
I think this freedom of choice that
Republicans attacking Obama are using
it's pure ideology but at the same time
universal health care is not some crazy
radically leftist notion it's something
that exists all around and functions
basically relatively well Canada most of
Western European countries so the beauty
is to select a topic which touches the
fundamentals of our ideology but at the
same time we cannot be accused of
promoting an impossible agenda like
abolish or private property or what now
it's something that can be done and is
done relatively successfully and so on
so that would be my idea to carefully
select issues like this where we do stir
up public debate but we cannot be
accused of being utopians in the bad
sense of the term
you